when you're uh one of our favorites
uh on this program and uh your
information is top-notch
which is why you're one of our favorites
and uh your information is that um
the head coach my guy at my alma mater
is thinking of leaving uh that earned
you a trip to the rich eisen show
and kindly bruce feldman of the uh
athletic and fox sports says okay
how are you bruce feldman how are you
doing today sir happy new year rich good
to be on with you happy new year to you
sir as well all right what gives what's
going on what do you know
with harbaugh in michigan well uh we
started hearing that there was some
rumblings that
the talk about jim harbaugh possibly
going back to the nfl i was told by uh
multiple sources is very real that there
would be interest
uh now where would he go
so we know that he started his coaching
career actually with the raiders i was
told he has a really good relationship
with mark davis the owner there
uh they have a quarterback which is
obviously a you know for anybody who's
looking at coaching jobs that is that is
a big piece of it um and then as a
couple of people i talked to over the
last 48 hours you know kind of detailed
it was like look the timing might be
very good here for jim harbaugh he just
led michigan to its first big ten title
in almost 20 years he obviously whooped
the archrival ohio state that was a big
piece it was like you know what he
hasn't won a national title but he has
he has accomplished a lot in the past
year and if he really wants to go back
to the nfl
this might be
an ideal situation in addition there's
another franchise that he knows very
well that he has some
from what i'm told some really positive
feelings towards people there and that's
in chicago with the bears so there's
some i think it's not just
the timing of
where what jim harbaugh has accomplished
if he's if he's tempted by going back to
the nfl but it's also some of the
potential fifths that are out there that
i think might be very tough for him to
pass up now obviously uh we're not
outing your sources here but i need to
know um why wouldn't this be
uh
a play potentially to restore
the money that was removed
by michigan based on the circumstances
of the previous years and last year
alone why wouldn't this be one of those
proverbial
college football money plays
bruce
j rich i think it has a lot to do with
just does he really want to go back to
the nfl he's 68 uh he was you know
unlike a lot of college coaches who have
gone to the nfl he was really successful
so it's not like oh how's this going to
work out i think you know what happened
with urban meyer in jacksonville i think
was a gut punch to a lot of college
coaches who have no nfl experience well
jim harbaugh has a lot of it both as a
player and assistant and then as a
successful head coach so i think
the timing on that look the money he
earned in in the incentive bonuses
because they they gave back made the
playoff yeah he ended up giving it back
to
to uh uh to staffers at michigan who got
squeezed or laid off in the wake of the
so i don't think
you know this is this is really a money
situation as much as it is
it's the timing ideal and is that
something where
i want to be at i mean you talk to
anybody who is coached in college and in
the nfl and they will talk about what a
grind
being a college coach is because at
least in the nfl you're off season you
have an off season in college it's
constant recruiting and there's also ask
you know the portal has made it so much
more chaotic uh how that kind of cycle
now is so i think
for for any coach i think the idea of
looking at an nfl opportunity if it's a
good one i think it'd be very tempting
especially the timing you and i talked a
lot about jim harbaugh being an ultimate
competitor and before this year
how would he leave michigan knowing i
didn't finish the job
i mean he
thumped the arch rival he won the big
ten title i mean that is those are those
are big accomplishments the question is
is he ready i mean at the same time he
also said after he won those games and
even after they lost to georgia was like
he feels like it's a beginning
question is it's a beginning to what i
mean
it wouldn't shock me if he stayed it
also definitely would not surprise me if
he ended up he ended up going to the
raiders or going back to the nfl bruce
feldman here on the rich eisen show and
look you know uh my ears to the ground
and i think you and i have had
conversations he he probably you know
he's got his guy and
what is it hecker right who who would be
his his uh his his player personnel guy
like he if he gets to bring his people
right and his setup then then
he he would go for the right situation
that if he wants to go back to the nfl
like and and and you know tires have
been kicked on him he on he on other
people throughout his tenure at michigan
i've heard as well and i don't hold it
against him at all man i mean like this
is
this is the way things go in reality so
i asked this next question hoping your
answer is no is is is part of what
you're hearing in the conversations that
you're hearing about his level of
interest the fact that he looked across
the field and he saw what georgia and
the 45 star recruits looks like and
knows what the gap is between his
current situation and what he's bringing
in and how much he'd need to
work a transfer portal and work this and
work that and i'm not saying he's not a
hard worker the man's the king of
grinding but just knowing the difference
and and would he maybe want to use his
his success now to just go to the nfl
now be based on the gap that we just saw
on the orange bowl
i don't have the you know a real answer
to that to be honest the one thing i you
know like i would say to that though is
ohio state has a ton of foreign
five-star players and they beat them now
most of them seem like they're on
offense well i just i i i have to
interrupt you bruce you used the word
thumped before i prefer that more than
beat can you continue to use uh emphatic
language like that when you refer to
that when playing
but the reality is like ohio state
recruits
more like alabama and georgia than
michigan and the rest of the you know
top 25 have
and they won that game now look it's
you know there's a lot of circumstances
that go into it i find it hard to
believe that jim harbaugh would look at
it and go i just you know i see where
yeah we beat ohio state but we're a ways
away from beating georgia you know like
i don't i don't think that would factor
into his decision to be honest i really
think it was like the timing to be a
college coach to be anywhere as a coach
right now for for more than six years
and remember jim harbaugh had never been
anywhere for very long as a coach you
know so
i that's again i'm not saying he's
leaving tomorrow we don't know how
things are going to play out with the
raiders i mean the raiders can make a
play off and who knows maybe versace
will lead him on up on a run to the
super bowl you know but the way
some of this stuff is shaping up some of
the conversations i've had with people
who are who know him who are around him
who also are you know plugged in to
to his situation as well as the nfl
situation with the raiders and a few
other places um
i think it's a i think it's really it's
one to keep an eye on over the next
couple weeks bruce feldman here on the
rich eisen show fox sports and the
athletic um
the transfer portal now in the world of
the nil now that we've got a full year
of nil of playing season niall i mean uh
under our belts is anything different
because you know we had we had um lane
kiffin on and he was lamenting the lack
of institutional
um guard rails in the ncaa about
players and where they're going and we
just saw
uh prime take the top recruit uh in all
the land and bring him to
an hbcu
in jackson mississippi and take him away
from tallahassee as well even though he
told me on the show i didn't take him he
didn't belong to them and i don't know
that was just a great conversation with
dion i'm just what the general sense of
things you know with caleb williams
going in and maybe losing his gig in
oklahoma while he went in to the portal
i mean what what is going on your
general sense
of everything in college football right
now it's just a it's a lot of volatility
in terms of i think there's a couple of
things to separate they're connected but
the nil stuff i think when caleb
williams jumped in the portal i think a
lot of people immediately assume this is
going to be go to the highest bidder now
i know of some situations that are not
related to caleb williams where there's
a couple of big time transfers who it
sounds like that is exactly what's
happening from what i've heard from both
coaches and people around caleb williams
was that this is more who who do i think
can give me the best chance to be
developed so i can hit the ground
running when i get to the nfl in two
years and be the most prepared
um and i don't know how confident
he and the people you know he listens to
were with the new system there that jeff
levy was coming in the new offensive
coordinator to oklahoma um now is that
going to be back with lincoln riley at
usc obviously lincoln rallies has
developed
three starting nfl quarterbacks now
between baker jalen hurts and kyler
murray
i mean that would seem like the most
likely fit i know there's other people
who are gonna who are gonna
take a big swing to try to get him and
make their case but i think when it
comes back to the the part that's really
interesting as we're talking about the
portal think about it this way so
the guy who ended up jumping to ou
uh dylan gabriel was a wildly successful
quarterback at ucf
he had gotten in the portal he committed
to ucla he was supposed to start classes
that you saw on monday at some point
monday afternoon when when uh
when caleb williams announces he's going
in the portal then all of a sudden hey
oklahoma might need a quarterback by the
way the system that oklahoma now runs
um that's one that dylan gabriel played
in at ucf dylan gabriel did not show up
you know in his classes at ucla instead
he 18 it and now he's expected to be the
quarterback at ou
and so
in this process now you have a lot of
guys who have basically
gone through the recruiting process but
now they've gone through and they've
gone evaluated in real college football
so you have a lot of players who are
weighing their options almost constantly
and i think so it's kind of set you know
depth charts into chaos because of it
and i think there's just a lot of moving
parts to this like i said because of the
nil aspect of it because of so much
uncertainty and i think for a lot of
coaches now they're going to probably
recruit as heavily off the portal if not
more to kind of restock their their
their depth charts because i think they
don't know as much about the unproven
commodities of college recruits as
they're coming out of high school and
that's the part that i think is way
different you're going to see a lot less
high school players i think probably get
offered because people are gonna have to
save room for all the movement that's
going on with the free agency from the
actual college players in the portal
yeah didn't dion say uh 20
of his
process is just is his high school
recruits i think that's what he said he
said and i think that's not that's not
that uncommon texas state higher you
know hired texas state
landed and signed no high school players
last year i mean they wanted to go all
in on the portal and i think you're
seeing that more and more where you can
have guys who are like okay
why why would i
you know kind of if you have an nil deal
lined up wouldn't you rather have the
guy who's the proven commodity than some
guy who was like evaluated as a
four-star guy but you really don't know
what you're getting until they've
actually done it in the games so i think
everybody's honestly is looking out for
their you know can they get their next
their job their own version of joe
burrow joe boro was a program changer
for lsu it worked out great i think
everybody's hoping that that they're
going to find some version of that and
coaches don't like this because they
they they can't count on a four-year
commitment from anybody signing a letter
of intent anymore is that what it is
yes and i think it screws up the power
of dynamic as it is because now the
players have way more power than the
coaches are comfortable with a lot of
coaches i'm not you know i'm not saying
all but a bunch of coaches were
uncomfortable with the nil because they
thought it was going to
change the power structure of how their
relationships are so outside of somebody
like nick saban who wins every year and
whose facilities are off the charts and
whose track record of turning kids out
for the nfl uh professionally is uh
without a question who what's the type
of coach that succeeds in this world
like like is it prime i mean that's what
i'm saying like somebody who knows how
to talk to kids who also knows how to
lay down the law for kids is respected
by kids
um can can work the transfer portal can
also create some spot where there's
enough buzz where there's nil money that
you can say
i can't guarantee it but you will have
the opportunity if you ball out to get
it i mean that's what i'm saying like
who who is the this is fascinating to me
i mean like because it sure doesn't
sound like urban meyer you know like the
iron fist let's this sort of thing or
like ryan day even lost a kid out of his
uh quarterback room right i mean so uh
i'm just yeah i mean i think on the on
the ryan day part of it i think so much
is like look they lost
alabama's best receiver the best
receiver in the sec jamison williams he
wasn't really getting on the field at
ohio state because they were so loaded
in that receiver room right i think you
know there are some circumstances that
are that way i i think what is going to
play best is the guys who have the track
record not only with transfers but of
developing players for the nfl that's
ultimately what they wanted i mean look
for a for
a window lsu had that where they were
able to go into the portal whether it
was whether it was joe burrow or you
know the best kicker that they ever had
or you know they're getting players
because they see it worked well then all
of a sudden after a while it gets stale
and it's like i think people are looking
for
where is the best fit for me and if a
coach can sell somebody on hey this
worked out great for that guy i think
then it starts because
right now i think everything is so
so tailored to what is the depth chart
what is it what is the plan you have for
me right and so you know i would expect
lincoln riley because his roster is a
mess you know what he inherited is not a
good situation they were a bad team
they are going to be selling the heck
out of their nil opportunities i know
usc is doing that you have a coach who's
who's developed a lot of nfl players now
and there's opportunity i am sure they
are you know they're going to be all in
on
making
uh the portal an attractive spot for
people to come out of there to go to usc
i mean look across town ucla has
actually done that you know there's a
running back who turned out to be a star
from ucla it started out at your alma
mater uh zach charbonnet turned out to
be a terrific player
we've seen them do that a lot where it's
like hey
we want a guy who's who's maybe more
mature and ready for another chance and
a lot of quite honestly a lot of kids
maybe come back if they didn't start out
you know if they were high school kids
from southern california maybe they
went someplace else and maybe they're
looking to come back home again so i
think what you know the la schools are
definitely
in the big market and i think they've
actually you know kind of managed it
pretty well to this point of how they're
trying to sell it to kids last question
for you bruce feldman uh i'm going to
ask you the question that i'm sure a lot
of my uh friends and fellow alums would
want to know the answer to if harbaugh
does get that nfl opportunity the way
that he wants it and he decides it's
best for him and his family and he's
he's had his run at michigan and it
ended um with a uh
one of the best seasons of michigan
football i've had since uh being there
when he was a a senior in college in
1986 who who would be the the next
michigan coach what what's that list
look like do you think
you know i would think they will
talk to both coordinators who have done
a really good job there but they're
younger guys both josh gaddis won the
who won the the uh broyles award as the
nation's top assistant he's the oc and
mike mcdonald did a terrific job as a
defensive coordinator if they did not
feel like those guys were ready to be
the head coach at michigan
i would think they would look at a bill
o'brien who has coached in the big ten
he's alabama's oc obviously you know
well-versed you know have from his time
at nick under nick saban now but also in
the nfl and around belichick i think he
would be attracted to them i could see
them being attracted to matt campbell
from iowa state
um then you get get into the question of
like would a guy like matt rule who is
really struggling in two years with the
panthers would he go you know what maybe
i'm gonna get ahead of the posse and
this would be a really good job to jump
on he obviously did a tremendous job
at baylor rebuilding that program
i would think those were the guys that i
think that that michigan would would
start out looking at
do you think that's going to happen
honestly what do you think
i honestly think it's it's 50 50 right
now i really think it's that that much
of a real thing
that much of a real thing bruce feldman
appreciate the time appreciate it sir
always a pleasure rich thanks for having
you got it bruce feldman at bruce
feldman cfb i follow him on twitter you
should too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here